[Music]
here we go again it's ps plus reveal day
and these are the new games that those
playstation plus subscribers can
download from tuesday the 4th of january
first up is persona 5 strikers on your
ps4 unlike the majority of persona
outings strikers is different a sidestep
in the jrpg's progression which brings
in hack and slash mechanics in the vein
of dynasty warriors cutting through
hundreds of weak enemies with ease
before fighting a far stronger boss
another change sees persona 5 signature
calendar system being shrunk down and
simplified substantially in this one
you'll be fighting in real time there's
no waiting for your turn in strikers but
you'll still have elemental damage and
spellcasting is here too the story
follows on from the phantom thieves last
adventure in persona 5 and now it's
summer break this is technically a new
story designed to help newcomers climb
on board this iconic series in a shorter
more linear affair but in reality you'll
be hella lost with many things the group
say if you haven't played persona 5.
those on ps5 remember you can play
persona 5 it's available for free
whenever you want it if you ever have
the time with persona 5 strikers
reviewers tell us it's a great game
averaging 8 out of 10. next up is dirt
i'm going to put some dirt in your eye
thanks pete dirt 5 to be precise on the
ps4 and ps5 a racing game which
surprisingly is nothing like dirt 4. let
me explain the dirt series grew into a
super simulation inspired outing but
that approach has gone and dirt 5 is
unashamedly an arcade racer with easy to
understand and pick up and play controls
the story is told through podcasts with
nolan north and troy baker playing your
rivals taking every opportunity they can
to put you down publicly if you've ever
played drive club this will feel very
familiar as it's made by the exact same
team who made that one of the best
elements in the game is the playground
mode a place to go to build your own
stunt tracks the weirder and more
challenging the better these can be
uploaded to the community as you all try
to outdo each other reviews for dirt 5
average at about 7 out of 10 which
officially makes this a good game oh
before we go to game three a quick
reminder that if you added the ps4
version of final fantasy vii remake to
your library last year you can now
update that to the full ps5 version
happy days that's quite impressive back
to january's ps plus and take a look at
deep rock galactic a game in which
you're a space mining dwarf shooting
waves of aliens deep rock is a
four-person cooperative shooter which
was given 9 out of 10 by ign but they
also gave death loop 10 out of 10 so
take that with a pinch of salt our job
here is to visit the depths of space and
return with loot there are four
character classes to use such as a
driller who has a flamethrower and
satchel charges a scout with a grappling
gun to get around the heavy gunner
waddles around with a minigun and has an
anchored zipline and the engineer who
can throw down a turret teamwork is key
in deep rock galactic and although you
can play solo a four player squad is the
right thing to do and that's because
many objectives require mining to be
completed while other members of the
team protect the objective against
swarms of enemies the caves are
procedurally generated so no two caves
will ever be the same the car loop of
returning to mine for more loot is
helped along by an upgrade system that
allows players to buy small upgrades
entire new skills and even cosmetics
including beards which are longer and
more ginger deep rock galactic has
overwhelmingly positive reviews on pc so
it's definitely something you need to
try on ps plus hi madam you're awesome
please share your thoughts in the
comments below and i shall see you next
time
[Music]